Brie Larson might be done playing
Captain Marvel after the Marvels she has
recently spoken up and expressed
frustration with all the hate that she's
been getting and Marvel studios's plans
for her have changed so the Marvels
could be the last time that we actually
see Brie Larson as Captain Marvel now
I'm sure she's going to go on to appear
in Avengers Secret Wars however if some
of what we've been hearing some inside
information about Secret Wars is true
then we really might not see her a lot
and the Marvel's is kind of going to be
her last big outing plus we know that
the MCU reboot is coming after Avengers
Secret Wars and from what we understand
this is kind of an opportunity for
Marvel Studios and Kevin VY to basically
pick what is working and keep it and
then toss out what isn't working the
only question is will Kevin fige and
Bray Larson think that Captain Marvel is
working or not and it certainly sounds
like at least right now Brie Larson does
not think that Captain Marvel is working
at least not for her not based off of
what she said recently and not based off
of this new report that we're hearing
that of course we're going to dive into
what we've been hearing is that Brie
Larsson is reportedly disillusioned with
her Marvel role as Captain Marvel and
she reportedly became disillusioned with
her role after all of the toxic backlash
and unfortunately she has indeed
received her fair share of toxic
backlash and she has a addressed it
before one time she stated I don't have
time for it the things that I have extra
time to really look at are like am I
eating healthy food am I drinking water
am I meditating have I called my mom
today however and unfortunately that was
when she first began her role as Captain
Marvel and now it seems like things have
changed a little bit and the hate might
have gotten to Brie Larson just a little
bit as well which is understandable
because now she is saying different
things and her future of Captain Marvel
doesn't sound so bright anymore recently
when asked about returning beyond the
upcoming the Marvels movie Brie Larsson
said does anyone want me to do it again
question mark this is a response that
tells us three things really one is that
yes she has continued to get hate she is
aware of it and two it is affecting her
obviously if you feel like nobody wants
you to play the role that's going to
discourage you from wanting to play the
role as well and the third thing is that
the future of Captain Marvel right now
is definitely clear and according to a
recent report Brie Larsson has straight
up said she doesn't want to play Captain
Marvel anymore this report is coming
from Joanna Robinson one of the writers
of MCU the reign of Marvel Studios and
she revealed this in an interview with
the podcast the watch and she is the one
who was also reporting that Brie Larson
has grown disillusioned with Captain
Marvel as well she stated in this
interview the future of those Marvel
icons was unclear the departure of
franchise anchors like Robert Dow Jr
Chris Evans and Scarlett Johansson had
already taken its toll as had the
shocking loss of Chadwick Boseman but
other MCU stalwarts were heading for the
exits the Guardians of the Galaxy cast
went on a farewell tour Brie Larson grew
disillusioned and Marvel tussled with
Sony in a custody battle over Tom
Holland she then later said Marvel
Studios put Brie Larson in a prominent
place in the MCU I don't know if Brie
Larson was the wrong person for the role
necessarily but the toxic backlash means
that Brie Larson doesn't want to play
Carol daners anymore so if this is a
true report then the hate really has
gotten to Brie Larson which means she
could either be replaced if she doesn't
come back or the MCU could simply write
her out which wouldn't be hard to do
considering what their plans are we'll
talk about how they could do that but
first big thank you to g2a for
sponsoring this video if you have not
heard of gate to Adventure please allow
me to introduce them to you they are
your ultimate destination for all things
Digital entertainment they have amazing
deals on things like gaming software and
gift cards to your favorite places like
Amazon Netflix Tinder and more and the
best part is is it all comes at an
amazing discount and is delivered
instantly g2a is your perfect Adventure
terminal and the best part is right now
g2a is throwing a massive Birthday Bash
and we are talking jaw-dropping
discounts exclusive limited time deals
and a gaming lineup that'll leave you in
awe right now offering discounts on
games like Mortal Kombat 1 fc24 and
cyberpunk 2077 so if you are ready to
level up your gaming collection and get
these games at amazing unbelievable
prices head to gate to Adventure over at
g2a.com
bday or click the link in the
description down below and remember when
it comes to Digital entertainment g2a is
the place to be now unfortunately
another thing that is kind of going to
affect Brie Larson remaining Carol dver
in the MCU is the box office performance
and what people think of the movie The
the fan ratings The Rotten Tomato
ratings that's all going to affect her
and sadly right now the Marvel's is
tracking lower than Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania and sadly there's a lot
going against this movie right now I did
a video a few weeks ago about how I
think this movie sadly is going to fail
not because I want it to because I do
not want this movie to fail I actually
think it's going to be a pretty good
movie and I do like Brie Larson but
unfortunately this movie really does
have a lot going against it and sadly
that's not going to help Brie Larson
want to remain Captain Marvel in the MCU
now she did say at one point in time
that a huge part of why she wanted to
play Captain Marvel was the connection
between Captain Marvel and Kamala Khan
in the comics and that is what this
movie is going to be about so hopefully
she at least had a lot of fun filming
the movie and I've met Aman volani who
plays Miss Marvel and she's a delight so
I'd like to think that her and Brie
Larson had a lot of fun on set but
here's the deal if these inside reports
are true and she's disillusioned with
the character and doesn't want to play
the role anymore it's not that hard to
kind of get her out of that role we've
learned that Marvel Studios really
wanted Brie larsson's Captain Marvel
Chadwick boseman's Black Panther and Tom
Holland Spider-Man to be the main
characters of the MCU moving forward
after Avengers endgame as mentioned it
didn't really work out for them because
of the unfortunate passing of Chadwick
Boseman the hate that Brie Larsson got
and the Sony will call it a kafuffle
when it came down to keeping Spider-Man
in the MCU they didn't know if he was
going to remain in the MCU so that put a
big damper in Marvel studios's plans
after endgame so their plans have
changed a little bit and perhaps Brie
larsson's Captain Marvel isn't really a
main focal point of the MCU but to be
fair right now there isn't really a main
focal point of the MCU there's no one
prominent character right now I said
this the other day but you could
probably argue for Doctor Strange and
Spider-Man but there's nobody really in
that Iron Man spot or Captain America
spot right now and here's what we've
heard about Secret Wars we've heard that
in the MCU the entire Multiverse is
going to start collapsing incursions are
going to happen left and right and
basically universes are going to die so
from what we've heard the TVA is going
to go to random universes and save
Heroes and bring them to one universe
that is stable and not being destroyed
so in that Universe we're going to have
a bunch of different heroes from other
universes together as of right now
that's really all we know we don't know
the reason the TVA is saving them it
probably is so they can kind of all
contribute to restoring the Multiverse
but again we haven't heard about that
and another thing we don't really know
is our universe what happens to our
universe does the TVA take people from
our universe and put them in this other
one or is our universe the place where
all of the heroes are going to be put if
the TVA decides to take people from our
universe to save them because it is
being destroyed then that's a really
easy way to essentially get rid of any
character and actor in the the MCU that
we have right now and based off of what
Joanna Robinson said before that is what
Kevin fuggy wants to do he essentially
gets to pick and choose what's working
and what's not working whatever is
working he brings into the new universe
that will exist after Secret Wars and
what isn't working he leaves behind so
sadly it's not that difficult to kind of
wash out any character at this point in
time which means if brie Larsson wants
to be done as Captain Marvel she
probably is going to be done now I hope
Captain Marvel 2 aka the Marvels is a
success even if it isn't a box office
success I hope the fans like it I hope
it gets good Rotten Tomato scores and
maybe that'll kind of revitalize Brie
Larsson to play the role and she'll
stick around but if that is not in
Marvel studios's plans if that's not in
Brie larsson's plans then it looks like
there's a very easy out and if the movie
doesn't do well which it's not tracking
to do well right now and Brie Larson
really is kind of done with the role
this could be the last time we see her
because if they are picking and choosing
characters from universes and and
putting them into one she could very
easily be left out which means she might
show up a little bit for Avengers the
King Dynasty but from what it sounds
like that movie is going to be pretty
grounded the superheroes are going to be
pretty grounded as well so maybe she
doesn't show up then and maybe she shows
up for a little bit in secret Wars but
it's a possibility that she might not
even show up then as well so I hope it's
not the case but this could be the last
time that we see Brie Larson as Captain
Marvel in the Marvels let me know what
you think about that down below does
this make you upset does this make you
happy I know there's people on both both
sides either way it is pretty sad that
she's gotten so much hate that it's kind
of discouraged her playing the character
but let us know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe stay up
to date on all the latest news and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
we're also on Twitter and Instagram if
you want to follow us on there and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof